quand vous allez rentrer à l'inter vous
allez pouvoir voir des chariots qui ont
été désinfectés au fond à droite on
rentre à la file d'attenté ne semble
arrêter personne pas plus que les
mesures sanitaires
les amateurs de jardinage sont nombreux
et les propriétaires font des affaires
d'or l'ouverture c'est sûr c'est très
achalandé ça vaut bien les consommateurs
sont au rendez vous beaucoup de nouveaux
jardiniers aussi donc oui nos ventes
sont en augmentation sur l'année passée
on a on se plaint pas au niveau des
ventes
en date d'aujourd'hui est à 55 %
d'augmentation depuis le début du mois
de mai une tendance à la hausse qui
avait été observé avant la crise sauf
que les attentes ont été surpassées
oui cet âge est présent de ne pas assez
tu as déjà de grézan mais c'est beaucoup
plus fort que le 25 pour cent quand même
qu'on l'avait prévu il ya plus réajuster
heureusement on était quand même rapide
donc on ne manquera pas de stock pour
l'instant ni vraiment pas inquiet et
devant un si grand nombre de clients
le propriétaire du floralies jouvence
estiment qu'ils seraient bénéfiques de
leur permettre d'ouvrir le dimanche
après tout vers la tous les dimanches
dresde année là on dirait un pelage
court 24 joueurs lorsqu'ils donnent à
peu près sur l'oubli demain 4 4 à 6
dimanche là juste pour passer la grosse
période de prêt à refermer nos dimanche
j'aurai très content de mon jeu
les clients rencontrés ou ne semble pas
pressé de revenir en arrière
j'ai commencé à apprendre les bienfaits
du rien faire le dimanche je pense que
ça peut être vraiment intéressant
peut-être devrait explorer la
possibilité peut-être d'avoir un congé
dimanche pour tout le monde
on peut adapter notre a de toute façon
venir une journée dense mais moi je
crois qu'ils ont de grandes joies du
repos chez paradis jardin et accessoires
la journée de congé du dimanche est la
bienvenue même qu'elle pourrait demeurer
en place après la crise bon
personnellement je serai très à l'aise
puis ce fut au tour de la maison
employés je pense qu'ils ont tous y sera
là ça fait plus grosse semaine les gens
je pense que les gens s'arrangent comme
ça c'était comme ça dans le temps puis
je pense que tout le monde s'en sortait
bien
les deux propriétaires s'entendent pour
dire que si la tendance se maintient ce
pourrait bel et bien être l'année de
tous les records
ici audrey paris radio canada qui